you know the phrase sometimes a little
bit of knowledge is a dangerous thing it
really applies to a clip we're going to
look at today of lara trump that's eric
trump's wife
donald trump's daughter-in-law and now a
fox news contributor we're going to look
at video of lara trump saying
she's against covet precautions because
she gets really happy she's thrilled
when her children get sick now the
context of all of this is that because
of the explosive spread of the virus
again because of the delta variant
particularly among unvaccinated people
um places around the country are saying
masks are coming back on
some increasingly employers are saying
you're going to need to be vaccinated in
order to work here remember that fox
news has a set of rules in place
where if you're not vaccinated and you
haven't proven your vaccination through
a portal that fox has which is like a
vaccine passport you have to keep
wearing masks when you work at fox news
etc so far this is happening on fox and
fox is doing a lot of this stuff
lara trump says a whole bunch of
different things that make no sense
whatsoever and that she's thrilled when
her children get sick so let's take a
look let's take a look vaccinated
americans fox news contributor laura
trump is here to react good morning
laura
good morning ainsley good morning i know
you have two school-aged children how do
you feel about the children under the
age of 12 we'll have to wear a mask
again right
well i i think it's absolutely ludicrous
first of all um we know the efficacy of
masks have been long disputed it was dr
fauci who a year and a half ago remember
told us all if it makes you feel better
wear a mask but remember
that was this is what how many months in
are we now 17 18 months in
for a couple weeks to prevent a run on
masks dr fauci and others did not come
out and say wear a mask then we learn
more and the the consensus among the
medical community has been
mostly unchanged for all but those first
couple of weeks we didn't have to wear a
mask originally he said it wasn't going
to really do anything oh come on then
they told us mass then they said three
masks they've gone back and forth on
this but as it relates to kids i mean i
can tell you it is almost impossible for
my three-year-old son to keep a mask on
so the idea that these kids are gonna
have to sit through an entire day in a
classroom with masks on you see the
videos this has real i'd like to speak
to the manager vibes guys i have to tell
you the kids who are waiting for the bus
crying because they don't want to have
to wear the mask it gives them headaches
from a social perspective they can't see
the faces of the other children
we know also if we're following the
science angel like we were supposed to
do the entire time that thank goodness
children do not get coveted in the same
way that adults do if they get it we
know that they get a very mild case of
it they're not the super spreaders they
that we originally were told they might
be
and so the idea that we're going to make
our children sit in school massed up all
day long i think is absolutely ludicrous
they're also not coming in contact with
germs that they need to develop an
immune system my daughter carolina last
week had a cold every parent knows
that's a nightmare i have to tell you i
was so thrilled because i know that she
is actually getting in contact with
viruses and germs and bacteria that will
allow her to develop an immune system
this is absolutely insane that we are
considering so this is another person
who can't first of all can't understand
you might consider someone other than
just your kid because carolina trump or
whatever the kid's name is
it when it because it's thrilling to her
that her kid got a cold
um that's not a reason to say no masks
for kids at all even as this is
spreading uncontrollably and the issue
isn't kids building up their immune
system against the flu or against germs
the point here is to keep people from
getting covet 19 which is a deadly
infectious disease that can kill some
people it can land some people in the
hospital but even for people that it
doesn't make very sick they can pass it
and then infect others and possibly kill
others she doesn't seem to understand
that she can't think about anybody other
than maybe herself and her own immediate
family
which seems to run in the trump family
if you guys have noticed and by the way
you don't have to get sick to develop
immunity you know this idea that if
you're not getting sick you're not
developing immunity we have things
called vaccines which her kids will
hopefully soon be able to get even at
their ages if she'll go and get them
vaccinated and there is some truth
very broadly to the idea that you don't
want to keep your kids in a bubble if
they have zero exposure from the time
their kids to anything from a very young
age there are some studies that show
that that can be problematic that's not
what's been discussed here it's not
what's being discussed lara trump's kids
have been out in the world this entire
time up until the pandemic and wearing a
mask at school which by the way you
still get germs
on your hands and then later you're out
on the playground and there's dirt and
there's different things and you're
around don junior's kids and all this
different stuff just wearing the mask at
school for a few months is not going to
do whatever it is she thinks it's going
to do to their immune system it's
absolutely nuts but not as nuts as this
next clip
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries from
the world's best filmmakers and right
now curiosity stream is giving you 25
off which comes out to just 14.99 a year
curiosity stream has a bigger selection
of documentaries than netflix hulu or
amazon i'm always finding documentaries
on curiosity stream that i can't find
anywhere else and they always have the
newest and most critically acclaimed
titles i just finished watching autonomy
which is all about self-driving vehicles
and emerging technology that's going to
have a big impact on our economy on our
political system i can watch curiosity
stream on all of my devices they have
documentaries on politics economics
history technology psychology you name
it and when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman
my audience will get 25 off that makes
it 14.99 a year
not a lot of money for the amount of
enjoyment that i know you will get from
curiosity stream and the link is right
underneath this video